اعلنت بريطانيا والولايات المتحده عن
شراكه جديده في مجال الطاقه تهدف الى
تعزيز امن الطاقه وخفض الاسعار وذكر بيان
المشترك صدر عن رئيس الوزراء البريطاني
ريشي سوناك والرئيس الامريكي جو بادن ان
البلدين سيقودان العمل على تقليل الاعتماد
العالمي على صادرات الطاقه الروسيه
واستقرار اسواق الطاقه وتنشيط التعاون في
مجالات كفاءه الطاقه والطاقه النوويه
المتجدده
وسينفذ المبادره وفقا البيان فريق عمل
مشترك جديد بقياده كبار المسؤوليه الحكومه
لبريطانيه والبيت الابيض
وقال بين المشترك صادر عن الرئيس الامريكي
جو بارد ورئيس الوزراء البريطاني ريشو
سوناك ان هناك او ان البلدين سينشيان
مجموعه عمل ثنائيه مشتركه رفيعه المستوى
لتسريع التعاون الفوري في دعم امن الطاقه
والقدره على تحمل التكاليف في المملكه
المتحده وعبر اوروبا واضاف البيان ان
الولايات المتحده والمملكه المتحده
ملتزمتان بتكثيف تعاونهما بما يقلل من
اعتماد اوروبا على مصادر الطاقه الروسيه
وقال البيان ان الهدف المشترك الفوري
يتمثل في تحقيق الاستقرار في اسواق الطاقه
وتقليل الطلب وضمان امن الامدادات على
المدى القصير مدعوما بالهدف طويل الاجل
المتمثل في دعم انتقال مستقر للطاقه
لتحقيق صافي بعثات صفريه بحلول عام 2050
واوضح البيان ان المبادره ستقودها مجموعه
عمل مشتركه بريطانيه امريكيه جديده بقياده
كبار المسؤولين في الحكومه البريطانيه
والبيت الابيض
وتعليقا على شبكه الامريكيه لبريطانيه
الجديده في مجال الطاقه قال رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني ريشي سوناك ان لندن واشنطن
ثقيفان معا في وجه الرئيس الذي قتل واضاف
في تغريده على تويتر ان البلدين يعملان
معا لتقليل الاعتماد العالميه على امدادات
الطاقه الروسيه
وكاله الاعلام الروسيه عن المتحدث باسم
الكرملاند متر بسكويت قوله ان روسيا تبحث
خيارات مختلفه فيما يتعلق بكيفيه الرد على
فرض سقف لسعر نفطها ودخل قرار تحديد سقف
لسعر النفط الروسي المنقولي بحرا عند 60
دولارا للبرميل حيز التنفيذ يوم الاثنين
الماضي وتقول دول مجموعه السبع واستراليا
ان القراره محاوله للحد من قدره روسيا على
تمويل حربها على اوكرانيا
معنى من لندن مراسل الجزيره محمد المدهون
كما ينضم الينا من واشنطن مراسل الجزيره
محمد الاحمد ونبدا معك محمد
المدهون حول هذه الشراكه الامريكيه
لبريطانيه
بشان الطاقه عمليا على ارض الواقع على
ماذا تنص بالضبط
الفنيه التجاريه والعلميه ولكن البعد
الاهم والذي يمكن ان نفهمه من صدور البيان
بشكل مشترك من الرئيس الامريكي ورئيس
الوزراء البريطاني الرئيس السونا هو البعد
السياسي الرساله الموجهه الى روسيا بان
حربها على اوكرانيا لن تؤثر على امدادات
الطاقه
لبريطانيا اوروبا وكذلك رساله موجهه الى
الداخل البريطانيه الذي يمر بازمه غلاء
معيشه غير مسبوقه منذ عقود وهذه الازمه
مرتبطه بشكل مباشر بالحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا هي رساله طمئنه يريد ان ينقلها
رئيس الوزراء البريطاني الى شعبه والى
الناس خاصه في ظل موجه الاضرابات العاصفه
التي تضرب البلاد تحديدا خلال اسبوعين
المقبلين قبيله اعياد الميلاد عمليه على
الارض ما الذي تعنيه حتى الان كشف عنها
الولايات المتحده تعهدت همم على المستوى
السياسي بان تعمل على زياده صادراتها من
الغاز الطبيعي المثال الى الضعف هذه
الواردات من الولايات المتحده الى المملكه
المتحده بلغت 3.9 مليار متر مكعب من الغاز
الطبيعي المثال في العام الماضي تسعى
الولايات المتحده الى ايصال هذا المستوى
الى 10 مليارات متر مكعب وكذلك الامر لن
يكون مقتصرا على المملكه المتحده انما
ايضا سيتم نقل هذا الغاز الطبيعي المثال
الى دول اوروبيه اخرى تحتاجه بالاستفاده
طبعا من البناء التحتيه التي تتوفر عليها
المملكه المتحده المتعلقه بمنصات استقبال
الغاز الطبيعي المثال واعادته الى حالته
الغازيه ايضا سيكون هناك فريق عمل مشترك
وهذا الفريق ايضا يحمل طبعا سياسيا لانه
هناك حوار استراتيجيه للطاقه بين الولايات
المتحده المملكه المتحده قائم منذ يشرف
عليه وزراء الطاقه في الحكومه البريطانيه
والاداره الامريكيه ولكن فريق العمل
الجديد هذا سيكون فيه مسؤولون رفيعوا
المستوى من البيت الابيض ومن مكتبي رئيس
الوزراء البريطاني لبحث تحديدا كفاءه
الطاقه كيف يمكن تقليل الطلب على مصادر
الطاقه خلال الشتاء المقبل وسنوات المقبله
طيب خلينا محمد المدهون من لندن ننتقل الى
واشنطن مع محمد الاحمد ما الذي سوف تكسبه
الولايات المتحده من هذه الشركه وما الذي
ستقدمه
لبريطانيا وماذا عن الاسعار هنا وتفاوت
هذه الاسعار مع مصادر الطاقه من روسيا
في الحقيقه هذا سؤال مهم حسن تم الكشف عنه
من خلال هذا الاتفاق الذي اعلن عنه
الاربعاء ان الولايات المتحده ستقوم
بتصدير حوالي 9 الى 10 مليار متر مكعب من
الغاز الطبيعي المثالي للمملكه المتحده
وهو ما يمثل ضعف الشحنات الامريكيه من
الغاز الطبيعي المثال المقدمه لندن خلال
هذا العام طبعا هناك اسئله كثيره حول
كيفيه تامين هذه الامدادات حسن بالنظر الى
ان الولايات المتحده كانت قد الدرامات
اتفاق مماثل في شهر مارس الماضي خلال
مشاركه الرئيس في قمه حلف شمال الاطلسي
بروكسل وتعهدت خلالها الولايات المتحده
بتامين 15 مليار متر مكعب لاوروبا في
مواجهه تداعيات الحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا
على امن الطاقه وايضا للتقليل الاعتماد
على الطاقه الروسيه لكن السؤال هنا همم في
الشنطه هو كيفيه تامين هذه الامدادات هناك
بالفعل مشاريع ضخمه لتوسيع تصدير الولايات
المتحده من الغاز الطبيعي المثال سيما في
تكساس والوزيانه لكن هذه المشاريع التي
تبلغ حوالي 30 مليار دولار حسن لن تدخل
الخدمه الا العام المقبل وبالتالي هناك
نساعي من الولايات المتحده للضغط على
شركات تصدير الغاز لتحويل شحناتها سواء
لاسيا او لبدان اخرى الى المملكه المتحده
والى اوروبا لانها في واجهه الصراع
الروسيه الاوكراني وتداعياته الكبيره على
القاره الاوروبيه خاصه
الغاز الطبيعي من روسيا الى اوروبا الى
حاله الركود في القاره الاوروبيه وبالتالي
هناك اسئله كبيره لكن المعلن لحد الان ان
هذه الخطوه تهدف اولا لتقليل الاعتماد على
الطاقه الروسيه تخفيف تداعيات الحرب
الروسيه
وايضا التسريع نحو الانتقال الى الطاقات
النظيفه والطاقه النوويه وهذه قضيه باتت
ملحه جدا في ضوء ما جرى في اوكرانيا اي
التاكيد على ان الولايات المتحده عبر مع
شركائها عبر الاطلس في طريقهم نحو التسريع
الانتقال الى الطاقات النظيفه كطاقه
موثوقه حسنا شكرا
لمحمد المدهون كان معنا من لندن